bismillah al hamdulillah salam alaykum
greetings a peace I made a host of the
Deen show and I have a surprise for you
al hamdulillah that we were able to put
together a film many years ago and we've
been asking people who wanted to view it
to contribute towards purchasing it and
those proceeds were going towards
helping to cover many of the operational
expenses that go behind running a TV
media program but now we're gonna
release it for the whole world to be
able to benefit from historical that's
why we did it
that people can go ahead and relate to
many of the struggles and challenges
that I went through and how I overcame
and how you can too
so insha'Allah this story can be a
benefit it's gonna be at the link below
you can go ahead and it's out there for
everyone to watch all we ask is that you
watch it on our channel on our youtube
channel and then go ahead and contribute
if you can to the campaign that we're
having this month the link will be there
also and inshallah we really sincerely
all of us here appreciate all the doors
all the constant support that you guys
have the LOV able to go almost going on
ten years almost 500 episodes going on
in 2016 and only with your with a loss
want Allah's help and your your support
we'll be able to do it at hamdulillah
thank you so much once again may Allah
bless you this Ramadan have a wonderful
Eid I'm did Allah thank you I'm excited
to let you in on this surprise well not
a surprise anymore go ahead and benefit
from this watch the film and enjoy thank
you so much Salaam alaikum peace be with
you
I am Not Afraid to stand alone
if allies by my side I am Not Afraid to
stand alone I am Not Afraid to stand
alone I am Not Afraid